two-time Super Bowl champion and now Pro
Football Hall of Famer
Terrell Davis yeah what's up rich good
to see you wearing your Hall of Fame
jacket yes you have the Kay Jewelers
ring that you received on your hand yes
you have one on the corner of the desk
right next to the MVP trophy that goes
to the Super Bowl MVP this year although
it was a different looking trophy it was
a night trophy when I got it yeah what
was it it was like a long trophy it had
like a star on it and so was like a tall
tree and as it went up it was a star
that was kind of tilted like this oh
okay
oh now it's just now it's a football
this is it heavy because I haven't held
it before please look at all day it was
holding the car now go ahead and lift it
what do you think we got it's deceiving
rich what do you mean he's to see if it
looks like it's super heavy but it's not
okay yeah well secret put four points on
just a moment for a second here and what
I'm so fortunate to do with the NFL
Network and know you for as long as I
have okay is that I have now from now
several times seen guys who have gotten
to know and work with who deserve Pro
Football Hall of Fame enshrinement go
through the process and it can be really
nerve-racking from time to time yeah and
then you go to Super Bowls and you don't
hear your name called on occasion and
then one year you finally do yeah and
then you come up to the next Super Bowl
to rest in the jacket yes and have the
ring on yes I had it I had to break the
jacket on Richard how does that feel
Terrell Davis that if the wait is over
questions are over the wondering is done
yeah it's it's in your hands it's not it
was great it really does you know um
like I said this point last year you I
was on yourself and we were asking a
question you didn't want to really talk
about it's hard to because you can't
control it what can I do to make it
happen zero and I try not to think about
it because when you want something so
bad but you have zero influence on how
it turns out drives you insane
so I prepared my mind both ways I said
you know what I'll prepare my mind if it
happens obviously I'll be thrilled if it
doesn't happen then I was kind of
preparing myself for the typical hey you
know what it didn't happen again
he's unfortunate you know
and congratulations to the other guys
who got in but I want to do that this
year in the ring I mean the folks in a
jewelers have really outdone themselves
yeah ring this this ring is beautiful
man this is called the the ring of
excellence and every hall-of-famer gets
this ring now you can see that right
there it's a beautiful ring and Hall of
Fame and trust Kate jewelers to design
this ring and create it and obviously
it's it's an exceptional ring and it's
one of the three things you get right
you get the jacket the bus and then a
ring is a third I'm part of three things
that Hall of Famers get and this is the
one you wear every day I mean the jacket
I don't wear the jacket every day but
you can wear the ring as many times as
you want to and it's subtle but it's not
subtle
mmm they call this the 10th table ring
right you send ten tables away you can
see this ring but how many tables is the
Broncos championship you know what meant
I've only worn those I've worn this ring
way more than I've worn both of those
rings combined mm-hmm
they're vote they're both spent all
special no question about it but there's
something different about this about
this one come on I don't I mean oh there
look we all know that there are hundreds
thousands of Super Bowl rings and that's
it that you write it's only 310 I
believe it's what open up what you're
jack because it oh yes I know it is uh
three o im3 off your 305 you were three
old 500l five but I think with the class
there's 310 of us up there was your
father you you were lucky to go and
speak when you did even though I know it
was raining Lee as well yeah because
when Kurt's that was my dad when I was
my pops - yeah I think so man crying
when you were out you know what yeah you
know what from hasn't happened
absolutely mess it was a great song yeah
that was great
so your pops was crying yeah and your
kids were eating cakes our pets they
showed your kids during your speech yeah
I look up and I'd other people are
laughing at me and they're showing my
kids on the big screen
another kid eating sour patch my
daughter she has my my wife's cellphone
and she's not giving up the phone Wow
look that's the way sometimes we've got
to get kids through events yeah granny
this ground was so against technology my
wife and I we'd watch other people in
the restaurants was like we're never
doing that we're never giving an iPad
shame to yourself now if we don't come
equipped with iPads phones everything
because you have to it would drive you
insane
I'm airplane rides oh my imagine
airplane ride slow back when we had to I
know right with no Terrell Davis here on
the Rich Eisen show so what do you who
do you think takes home yeah right now I
got my mid my mid week selection but you
know we got the show on Sunday man so
you were getting out that's why was you
say you you are part of the part of the
no not a part of the eight and a half
out or they even half hours or eight
outlets what do you all we all know
there's only four of us who do all eight
yeah I'm more than that
mooch Curt Irv okay we're doing all
eight and a hands-on okay so I'm dumb
that's like you're you in part you're
doing part of doing part but I'm not
sure if I'm even on the set with you
guys I think I'm on location somewhere I
can tell you you're doing seven and a
half hours of it just don't know I'm not
doing that think I'm so no I'm just
letting you know they wanted me to let
you know you're doing say who was the
breaking news a day who is who is they
rich you know is there a part of you
that thinks that I'm serious right now
not zero information doesn't exist when
it comes to so who's your who's you who
is your mid-week patriots right now all
right what do you think now what would
be what would make you you know it's
from Patriots the Eagles over the next
two and a half days I know right it's
it's uh just being down here right I
think just being down here just getting
a feel for the game I like just come
down and and get a sense for what people
are saying I remember being in San Diego
as a player right in Super Bowl xxxii
and I'm we came down that we can just
sit sitting in the hotel room and
hearing everybody say that the Patriots
or at that time was a Packers yep
the Packers are when they get yes right
they were gonna go back to back back to
back as a player the motivation you
gained from that just sitting in that
room I mean Doug Peterson can't ask for
a better motor can't pay for that and if
they take it the right way and harness
that energy this and focus what we did
in San Diego we were able to come out
and beat the Packers yes and a lot of
that in my opinion was before me at
least it made me narrow my focus because
I'm like okay we got shock the world
well also hell so also have to help to
have a guy number seven you know no
questions you got number nine here for
the Eagles
he's been playing very well luli and
they have a good team so they're not a
team that got here by accident they're
not a team that's you know they pulled
off two miraculous wins they're a solid
team that can win they can beat the
Patriots with talent right now there's
that word did you hear that word was
that solid they are solid solid solid is
always what you want if I told you hey
Terrell Davis would you want Earl Davis
you were a solid running back I take it
thank you well you would not know solid
textile that sounds good with all sorts
of negative connotations okay they're
solid team all right what's another one
they even have adjectives like
championship they have a 1 1 1 an NFC
championship that's come on man
how many 8 up C champions do you know
like I think you remember not the last 5
years there were a lot of Eagles the
Super Bowl team a loss in Super Bowl
okay so they're not I mean there are
good T there are they're good solid team
that but they have to play the thing
about them is that they have to play
their best football right did you expect
Nick Foles to play the way he played in
the title game if they can give that
nick foles mm-hmm
bring him in that stadium behind you
okay okay yeah but do you really think
Nick Foles is gonna have the
game of his life two weeks in a row no
that's it that's why I'm leaving but
that's right that's right
and every Nick ends with Kate and every
kiss begins with Kay hey jewellers at
Tyrell there's Gore Davis it in warm
eight real quick we had we had Willie
McGinest here yesterday he was the one
who brought out the trophy last year
when the Patriots well and he was
cursing up a blue streak and whatever
and it was all sorted you brought out
the trophy when the Broncos won would
you have brought it out for the Panthers
or did they have a Panthers sitting by
you Justin no I said I didn't actually
bring the trophy out I was the first to
one I was in the first leg and all okay
they were handing over my hit baton yeah
because I wasn't initially part of it
okay and right before the game had ended
I told Tracy Pearlman I said Tracy's
Leslie yeah I know we'll be great mm-hmm
if I were to hold a hand a trophy off to
the Broncos yeah when they win this game
yeah and she's like that's great idea
so I went out on the field but then I
had Brett Favre they had Joe Namath and
they had Lynn Swann already discussed to
do it Wow
so Landon was the third with the person
that was gonna head off to the Broncos
I'm with the Lannister hey Lynn hey uh
everybody know what man how about how
about we switch yeah cuz uh
Brett Favre I took his spot he was first
and Lynn was like he's like no he told
me that he really wanted to he said he'd
like this moment he's dreamt of this
moment he was laughing and I was that
buddies plans I okay man whatever you
just plan that's like are you serious
he's like yeah yeah I'm I've dreamt of
this moment so I'm gonna take it to the
Broncos I'm thinking wait a minute man
if the Steelers were up there you won't
even have to ask me I would volunteer
hey Lynn I think you should take this
trophy yeah because it's only
appropriate that you do that so I didn't
get a chance to give the trophy to the
Broncos oh thank you laughs now you
could take it up with him every summer
in camp yeah yeah yeah he's at USC right
now so now okay
oh hey and Georgia was there at the
final we were there it was a great
season man is so close it was the
highest of the highs and was the lowest
of the lows and like Oh two
it's bad hey speak to Vikings fans - oh
my goodness I know one week to the next
good to see you sir thank you I will see
you to rel Davis let me just sit my plug
one time before no Valentine's Day is
coming up right yes so rich you like
winning on Valentine's Day wait you
gotta win right here's my advice go to
your local K jeweler store or K calm to
find a special gift so that you are
winning cake amor special or your local
cake jeweler dealer yes fantastic you
very good men said event at Terrell
underscore Davis and TD will be on NFL
Network with me for all eight and a half
hours for the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience